what's going on guys this is rob and in
case you guys didn't know
season four nexus war just released in
fortnight now is a perfect time to jump
in
if you haven't downloaded fortnite
already use my tracking link in the
description below to download fortnite
for free and i do want to say thank you
to epic games
for sponsoring this video but here's the
thing guys you guys know i'm a marvel
comics fan
but you guys know i'm a marvel comics
fan i've been reading it for like 25
years or something like that like
i'd love to say i know almost everything
there is to know about marvel
and in this season you can team up with
marvel's greatest heroes and villains
including thor
iron man she-hulk storm doctor doom
wolverine
and more not only have the marvel heroes
and villains landed on the island
but so of their iconic locations okay
hold on a second hold on a second hold
on a second
did you guys see that right like peely
peeley the banana with with banana claws
[Laughter]
that is amazing i need that right like
they're little bananas
i absolutely beneath i absolutely
absolutely banana that i absolutely
need that okay i'm sorry uh continuing
on
continuing on so you can drop onto the
island and visit new and upcoming
locations
like doctor doom's domain in latviria
sentinel graveyard
and more so you can take up these
superpowers like doctor dooms
arcane gauntlets groot's bramble shield
silver surfers board
and more that are all arriving over the
course of this
season so make sure you guys check out
the link down in the description
make sure you guys check out fortnite
and have fun
playing out there what's going on guys
this is rob
and welcome back to the be not beyond
omega level
uh too powerful for the mcu and this is
a video series that we have where we
basically run over characters
that are just too powerful for the
marvel cinematic universe right that if
you put them in there
they would obliterate everybody and in
this video we're talking about herald of
galactus
iv now thor has had a whole bunch of
different versions over the years in
marvel comics right he's appeared
in a bunch of different ways we've seen
thor in his warriors madness
which is basically like wolverine's
berserker rage what this means is that
if thor fights long enough and hard
enough he'll basically lose himself in
the conflict right he'll go into like
this
you know almost mindless ferocious state
and which his power is something like
doubles or triples right he just goes
nuts and and it's almost impossible to
talk him down
uh and that in that mode like thor just
regular thor
you know in a warrior's madness would
crush everybody in the mcu
but you've also seen thor where he was
like rune king thor right where he
absorbed like the norns and he basically
went on the quest that odin went on
and for the most part kind of became
odin although a little more powerful and
was like a multiversal character right
that happened during the events of
ragnarok
it was can't really snap it was that
fast we saw that version of thor for
maybe like six or seven pages
before he went back to normal right so
that version of thor was was super op
the herald of galactus version of thor
came during the donnie kate's run
and the idea behind this is that
following the events of the war of
realms which was basically the end of
jason aaron's run for those of you guys
who don't know when it comes to comic
books you basically have what are called
runs and the reason why they call that
is because it's just
a chara like a writer's take on that
character and so
so take for example like jason aaron's
run that started with a with a comic
called
thor god of thunder and then ran all the
way up until the end of war of realms
right where like
pretty much all the realms of asgard
ended up going to war against the
villain um
yeah what was his name malikith that's
what it was he's so forgettable they
ended up going up against the villain
malekith he basically kind of initiated
this massive war
the story was great once that was all
done odin had been dead for a little
while and thor ended up taking his place
he became
the new king of asgard and so during
that time you ended up having galactus
who showed up on asgard
from like the middle of nowhere now it's
not the first time galactus has done
that and in fact he's actually fought
odin which i believe i have that video
down
in the description uh actually i'll just
post the whole thor playlist i think
it's down in there
it's really cool but what ends up
happening is galactus basically shows up
there
tells thor i need your help right like
there's a force called the black winter
coming
and it's gonna kill us all and so thor
ends up helping galactus track down
five individual planets that if galactus
consumes will give him enough power
in order to take on the black winter now
here's the reason why that matters
when it comes to galactus he as most of
you guys know he travels around the
cosmos just
consuming worlds right and by and large
this is just the role galactus plays as
marvel marvel prescribes it
the truth about this is that galactus is
just a giant source of energy that's
really all he is
but in order to maintain his energy
source he has to consume worlds that are
capable of supporting life right so
life-sustaining worlds they have to have
a particular energy signature right so
it's like
if you could only ever eat hot dogs it's
basically what galactus is
and that would be an amazing life to
live if you could just eat hot dogs
not probably not hot dogs maybe like
like
pad thai that would be amazing if you
like had to eat pad thai all the time
dude i would love that life but uh but
basically uh these worlds are normally
just
average worlds right these five
particular worlds are more enriched in
life-sustaining energy than any other
worlds in the cosmos
and so when galactus consumes these he
basically ends up becoming powerful
enough to take on
the black winter leading up to that
because of the fact that thor was going
to help him
you know basically travel to these
worlds and they didn't really know what
kind of resistance they were going to
encounter
but thor was imbued with a portion of
the power cosmic and what this did is it
amplified the existing power of thor
which came in the form of the thor force
now the thor force is
basically the same thing as the odin
force the difference is that odin
odin's odin force that that entire
premise is basically just the life
energies of his brother's villian v
that merged with thor himself when they
first fought certain and lost
that's really all that is but
essentially it's just a massive source
of energy
marvel's pretty ambiguous about it right
it's like the power cosmic from galactus
it's just a source of energy that lets
them do stuff but where the odin force
is called that because it belongs to
odin that same source of energy belongs
to thor and it's called the thor force
assembly just
seems to pass from one person to the
next but basically it means that if thor
with a thor force alone
was powerful enough right was was
powerful enough to safeguard
asgard and being like the strongest of
the asgardians and the most capable of
them
right with with odin out of the way the
most powerful of them
then the power cosmic boosted even
further right it pushes its powers
even further along the line now this
story basically ended up giving us the
revelation that where galactus consumes
worlds the black winter consumes
universes
right and originally what happened is
the black winter had consumed the
universe that galactus originated in
and that when galactus was reborn into
the maine marvel universe he was
supposed to be a herald of the black
winter
he basically ended up bailing out right
he ended up being like nah it's not
going to happen
and just kind of avoided his duties as
they had originally been charged and the
black winner had been tracking him down
and ultimately locating him in the main
marvel universe right that's basically
what happened over the course of six
issues but but when you're talking about
herald of galactus thor
you're talking about a guy who is for
the most part this nigh
unstoppable force and to give you guys
perspective there really
are no limits to the power cosmic in
terms of how the power of cosmic has
been used over the years
that's what's waxing waned right that's
what's changed originally in the power
cosmic
you know originally with like silver
surfer when he had the power cosmic
he could do things like time travel he
could move faster than the speed of
light
he could like you know give people
powers take powers away there was really
no limit to it
but what marvel ended up finding as time
went on was that one
swords on the silver surfer proved to be
the most popular when they focused on
like the the humanity of the silver
surfer for lack of a better word he's
not really human
he's from a planet called zen law but
when they focus on the character of
silver surfer
those prove to be the most powerful but
two you couldn't have this scenario
where a person was given the power
causing by galactus and then by all
standards of measurement
seemed to be on par with galactus and
power yet was somehow his subservient
right and so
uh you ended up seeing like the silver
surface powers not really waxing wayne
and decrease
in in terms of what he could do but you
ended up seeing him use less and less of
those various abilities right there's a
big difference there
but the difference is there nonetheless
and so because of that uh
when you when you have thor assuming
that he has the power cosmic in the same
capacity that like silver surfer did
one of the things that we saw was that
thor killed galactus right that's
literally what happened in the story
like
thor ended up killing galactus uh like
literally he took the power cosmic away
from him
and that's what's so crazy about that is
if thor can take the power cosmic away
from galactus then it means the thor can
manipulate the power of cosmic in its
entirety it means
he was on par with galactus power or at
least that seemed to be the case because
it's basically a two-way street
that's one of the small little changes
or really it looked like a small change
that was made by donnie kate's there was
a huge change right and so
what you're talking about is a version
of thor that has the power cosmic of
galactus
if they threw him in the marvel
cinematic universe i mean sure he would
fall to the power of the infinity stones
because the reality stone can control
reality
and of what uses thor with all that
power if he's utterly convinced by
somebody manipulating the reality stone
that he's locked inside of a box right
like if that's what they trick him into
believing
then you know that's what that's what it
is and that's just if they decide to
create an illusion using the reality
stone
they could very well just build a box
around him and he just can't escape from
it right a box is just
too strong for him to get out of that's
the kind of craziness that you come
across
so thanos wielding the infinity stones
no i mean thor you know
like herald of galactus thor would
probably lose uh but thanos not wielding
the infinity stones you guys remember
that fight that he had with thor at the
beginning of infinity war
that fight would have been over like
that but it would have been done with a
quickness like thanos would have felt
would have fallen
so fast right because mjolnir is a
powerful weapon in and of itself right
in the sense that it's literally
a sentient storm trapped inside of a
giant chunk of rock or a giant chunk of
metal
so using the power of like a cosmic
storm against someone like thanos
you would think would be more than
enough to take him out and had we seen
mjolnir
during the events of infinity war and
avengers in game that's probably exactly
what would have happened hence the
reason why it was destroyed
leading up to those events i think it
would have been more impressive if
thanos had destroyed
mjolnir but i think it's a little more
interesting to have seen that that hella
was the one who did it at least
it gave her character a level of power
that otherwise you wouldn't really have
been able to understand
because odin was gone at that point and
it kind of solidified things
right that's one of the things that i
kind of see a lot to sidetrack for a
second people ask like
why was hello the one who was able to
destroy thor's hammer because what other
measurement of power would they have had
right we didn't really know how powerful
certain was the four escape from him for
the most part
we know how capable loki is but loki can
be easily defeated he was defeated by
the avengers right so
he's powerful but not all powerful we
haven't seen the full on limits of
doctor strange
but there's no reason to believe doctor
strange would have fought hela in the
first place she wasn't there so
having her destroy thor's hammer was
kind of this sort of etched in stone no
pun intended
indication of how powerful she was the
funny thing about this and this is
what's so
wild is that if you look at the events
of thor ragnarok
you can actually see how they would
create mangog how they could basically
say man gog was a result of hella and
odin's actions
and man gog let me tell you something
they put man gog in the marvel cinematic
universe
like he would have been able to do what
surter did right like certain
obliterated asgard
that would have been the man gog like he
would have just ripped the entire place
apart because
he was a villain that like odin was
afraid of right like man gog shows up
and odin's like okay
man like we gotta run
[Laughter]
it was pretty wild to see nonetheless
right hilda galactus thor
this is a guy who would who would
decimate the entirety of the mcu
and i can't really think of any
characters they could invoke outside of
thanos wheeling the infinity stones or
some other kind of
high-level reality warper that would be
able to go toe-to-toe against him
anybody with sufficient telepathy it
wouldn't matter right so if you had like
charles xavier of the x-men the leader
of the x-men in the mcu
it wouldn't matter right it's not like
charles xavier can dominate the mind of
galactus
there's no real reason he to believe
that he could dominate the mind of
herald of galactus thor
you know when you have these characters
like this they're super overpowered
right so
for the most part heroic galactus thor
would crush the entirety of the mcu it
would
it wouldn't even be a contest and i
can't really think of a way for them to
win
like i can't really think of a way in
which the characters could somehow
overpower herald of galactus thor
because there's no real way to end run
the power cosmic it's not like you can
use like the casket of ancient winners
that you saw in
you know the thor movie when the frost
giants like froze everything it's not
like you can use that i mean that's not
gonna work against him
doctor strange maybe but that assuming
that assumes this power is on par with
herald of galactus thor which
i'm being honest i doubt uh you know
it's it's
it's kind of a wild scenario right so
this is one of those characters they'll
never put in the movies
uh and if they do it'll really be like
more of a symbolic thing
but i don't think you'd ever really see
him lose his mind and face off against
the avengers because
none of them could stop him right he
would he would he would kill them all
in a matter of minutes right then like
that fight would be over in
minutes it would be over that fast right
so i'm curious
what do you guys think right do you guys
think hero of galactus thor is that
powerful when it comes to the mcu
i mean this guy's broken in almost every
conceivable way just in terms of the
power he has and what he can do
he looks good but like no that's not
gonna happen
so let me know down in the comments
section if you guys are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace